joining us today to talk about this and
a whole lot more is Bill ottman hey
welcome back to me yeah good to see you
Tim cast yeah my name is Bill I'm the
founder CEO at mindsminds.com
m-i-n-d-s.com not
the I need to getminds.com so that
people don't think that we're a coal
mine operation Tim has brought that up
many times before but yeah we're a free
speech social network
focused on actual first amendment
content policy
um I think Twitter is slowly getting
there but they are not there and uh
they're still doing
these interstitial content policies all
over the world and and following content
guidelines of places like the EU so we
got to be careful of that and hold Elon
to account we love you Elon but you got
to open source all the code and Go full
free speech cool